you are watching ColdFusion TV
hey welcome to another ColdFusion video
so recently may have heard about the
latest project from Google X and for
those of you that don't know Google X is
the experimental division of Google so
after tackling self-driving cars Google
X is looking into drone technology a
latest project was kept secret and under
wraps for two years and finally it's
been unveiled and it's been titled
project wing let's take a quick look to
see what all the fuss is about project
wing is a direct answer to Amazon's
prime air a drone delivery service that
Amazon says will get products to your
door within 30 minutes project wing
broadens the scope a little from Amazon
as Google says its long-term goal is to
develop drones that could be used for
disaster relief by delivering aid to
isolated areas according to the BBC they
could be used for earthquakes floods or
extreme weather events the drones could
take small items such as medicines or
batteries to people in areas that
conventional vehicles just couldn't
reach according to a quote by Astro
teller one of the founders of Google X
he states that even just a few of these
being able to shuttle nearly
continuously could service a very large
number of people in an emergency
situation
Google X spokesman go on to say that
emergency services will now have a brand
new set of tools for solutions within
crisis situations interestingly enough
project wing is currently being tested
only in Australia in Queensland to be
exact but this is only because US
federal aviation laws are much too
strips in the u.s. to allow for free
flight testing one of the cool things
that our news outlets seem to be
ignoring is the actual aeronautical
design of the cell flying vehicle it has
a wingspan of 1.5 meters weigh is 8.5
kilograms and it's a VTOL aircraft VTOL
stands for vertical takeoff and landing
there's an idea first developed in
Europe but slow American adoption in the
early 1960s it was a revolutionary
concept basically a craft could take off
vertically without the need for a runway
and then propel itself like a regular
aircraft once in the air two of the most
famous examples of this craft would be
the harrier jump jet and the v-22 osprey
another cool factor is the flying wing
design this means that the craft can fly
more efficiently faster and travel much
further distances than when compared to
traditional quadcopter drone designs by
the way I only know of this because I
actually used to be obsessed of planes
as a little kid nice shame but back on
topic there still are a whole host of
issues to deal with before commercial
application some of these include
product theft Wireless hijackings and
proximity sensors not being fast enough
to detect potential crashes not to
mention government Aviation Regulations
and fear by the UNTAC savvy public
google.x themselves say that this
prototype is still years away from
production but this along with Amazon's
drone plans do give some insight into
the future direction of small package
delivery and disaster aid for that
matter anyway that's all from me for now
but let me know what you think in the
comments section below
I personally find the stuff very
interesting but I'm neither one way or
the other I'm not really on the edge of
my seat and I'm not really against this
either so I'm not you guys thing anyway
thanks a lot for watching another cold
fusion video I'll catch you again soon
for the next video and while we're here
please check out some other videos I'll
leave some links playing it for a bit so
you can just click on whichever topic
interests you the most and I'll see you
again soon cheers guys it's me thinking